[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK CHMARNY: Welcome.
Welcome to our
session on DEV101.
One platform for Your Functions,
Applications, and Containers.
Maybe the first
question, how many of you
attended the DEV108
session yesterday
introducing Knative
and Overview?
Good.
If you haven't, that session
did a really good overview
of general drivers
for the project,
some of the reasons for
Google to open source Knative
as well as introduced
a lot of the partners
and open source
frameworks that are
collaborating with us on that.
It might be worth
giving a watch.
All right, so let's start
with maybe a-- oh, by the way,
there is a video of that
session available already today,
so DEV108.
Let's do quickly-- maybe
start with a little intros.
VILLE AIKAS: Hi,
I'm Ville Aikas.
I've been at Google
for about 11 years.
I've been working in the
cloud for about nine or so.
I was one of the first engineers
on the Kubernetes project.
I did Cloud Storage and a few
other open source projects
as of late.
Like Helm, I've been
involved, service catalog.
And most recently, Knative.
All right.
MARK CHMARNY: And my
name is Mark Chmarny.
I'm one of the technical
program managers
responsible for
service at Google.
All right, so
apparently I'm hearing
Kubernetes is pretty
popular nowadays,
a great understatement,
I suppose.
It's growing
popularity has really
driven to become de facto target
for many of the workloads.
And why not?
People are benefiting from the
abstraction of the underlying
infrastructure.
It simplifies a lot of
the pains related to that.
The broad support from
pretty much every single one
of cloud service
provider nowadays also
assures a lot of portability
for your workloads.
And the rich ecosystem
of point solutions
filling in the gaps
around Kubernetes
means that you can
take your solution
and really kind of
adapt it and deploy it.
So overall, I know there is
still room for improvement.
I think we can still
make it a little better.
But overall the
operator experience,
the person who manages
Kubernetes, is pretty smooth.
But how about the developer?
How about the developer
experience, people
who build on top of Kubernetes?
Well, we think that that
experience is not as great.
I think there is still a
lot of room to improvement
because developers,
on the end of the day,
really just want to write code.
Unfortunately today, if you look
at the experience of developer
on Kubernetes, a lot
of the work in addition
to writing code also kind
of mimics the experience
of the operator.
There is a fair
amount of plumbing
to do, a fair amount
of networking,
fair amount of
implementation and so forth.
So I'm going to
introduce, again,
because apparently every session
has to introduce Knative.
So we've introduced
Knative again.
For those of you who have not
attended a previous session,
just a quick highlight, a
Kubernetes-based building
blocks for serverless workloads.
So one of the key drivers
or key properties of Knative
is that it sets some key
primitives for building
applications on top of Knative.
It provides initially build,
eventing, and serving.
And those are very first efforts
to simplify that experience,
and we're going to go after
other areas pretty soon, too.
It solves many of the
modern development patterns.
What I mean by modern here
is that, if you are bringing
a database, a single-node
database, probably
not the greatest place to run
this on top of Knative today.
But if you're looking
for a microservice
to build microservices,
stateless microservice
or Twelve-Factor
applications, Knative really
solves a lot of big
problems or issues related
to deploying on
top of Kubernetes,
those type of workloads.
Knative also implements
a lot of good learnings
from Google, including 10 plus
years on op engine, Kubernetes,
and Istio itself from the
open source community,
as well as a number of
contributions and feedback
and inputs from our partners.
So these are the companies, like
Red Hat, IBM, Pivotal, and SAP,
that have worked with us
before we even opened the repo,
over the last six months or so.
We really could
not have been where
we are today without them.
In addition to
that, we also have
started collaborating very early
with a number of open source
frameworks out there,
function as a service
frameworks, that are kind of
building on top of Kubernetes.
And the signal
that was coming out
of that that was really
good is that many of them
already are either taking
Knative as an ingredient
into their stack
or replatforming
the entire framework
on top of Knative
to simplify a lot of
the boring tasks that
are related to running your
framework on top of Kubernetes.
All right, so very quickly, if
you look at our documentation,
if you look at about any of
the materials we publish,
we often talk about
the different personas.
We talk about the developer.
We talk about the operator.
I think I want to
take a very quick
30 seconds here to just capture
some of the differentiation.
The people who
contribute to Knative,
who write code and improve
the Knative stack itself
are the contributors here.
They help the project
and improve it.
Then people who take that
code and instantiate it,
create an instance of
that and run it there,
we call them operators.
They can do that on any
certified Kubernetes instance
that are offered as a service.
Everything that we're
going to show you today
is going to be on top of
GKE, but the limitation
should not be there for any
of the demos to reproduce it.
And then on the
end, the people who
are consuming that service
that is being instantiated
by the operator and using only
the APIs are the developers.
And really today,
everything we're going to do
is we're going to
focus over here.
I think there, frankly,
could be another session
about the operator and the
community at large, too.
All right, so,
Ville, why don't you
give us a quick
overview of the objects
and give us maybe a
demo later on, or two?
VILLE AIKAS: All right, so
again, thanks for coming.
So that was a lot of great
information [INAUDIBLE]
on why we did some
of these things
and what we are
focusing on today.
And that really
is the developer,
as in why do you care, right?
So what we are going
to be doing is--
maybe switching this line--
it's the green one.
OK, so when we started building
this thing, one of the things
that we wanted to make
sure, it's easy for you
to come in this
platform and to be
able to feel very
comfortable and feel
very at home with this.
So when you go ahead and
come into a new system,
you shouldn't have to
have a very huge cognitive
overload of understanding
all kinds of different things
that you might not
care about right now.
So when you come to Knative,
the first day experience
should be extremely simple.
You should be able to come in,
and you should be able to say,
hey, I've got some
code over here.
I would like to run it.
So we want to make sure that
experience is really easy.
We also want to make
sure that the API
surface is familiar to you
if you have used Kubernetes.
So if you come into
Kubernetes, and all
of a sudden you have to do
something that is not native--
no pun intended-- then it's
very tricky for you to go ahead
and say, well, wait a minute.
I want to do this, but
when I use your system,
I have to do that.
So let's go ahead and take
a quick look and see--
can we switch the demo
machine-- and just see
what does it feel like when you
come into this on your day one.
MARK CHMARNY: Very
quickly, I just realized,
I've been mispronouncing
K-native the whole time.
[LAUGHTER] I think there is
over-under going on Twitter
right now.
So very quickly,
just to lay out,
because we're going to
be doing a lot of demos,
you're going to see
a lot of console.
It's going to be three panels
throughout the entire session
today.
We're going to, on
the very top, we're
going to see the
current workloads, which
we don't have any right now.
But we are going to spin
up some in a minute.
On the bottom left, we're
going to just quickly see the--
we're going to use Kail,
which is an open source
project to view and stream
logs from Kubernetes.
We're going to see the logs.
They are in a
different namespace.
And over here, we are going to
be running a bunch of commands.
All right, so everything
I'm going to show you
again is on top of
GKE, on top of Knative
that's being instantiated
using the documentation that's
in the repository.
So if you wanted to reproduce
any of what we show you today,
you could do that right away.
All right, so let's
apply that manifest.
And again, Ville was
talking about Knative
being idiomatic or intuitive.
If you've worked on
Kubernetes before,
Knative wants to
use your experience
with Kubernetes
itself and leverage
that to enable
you to be a better
developer on top of Kubernetes.
So we quickly see
Knative spun up a--
let's take a look at maybe
that manifest itself.
We've used a very simple, as
simple as physically possible,
manifest in here, deploying
a pre-built container.
You've seen that
yesterday, maybe in a demo.
You've seen this many times.
What Knative done
here for you, however,
is plumbed up all the other
things, connected logging,
deploy your routing, and
everything like that.
So let's maybe navigate
quickly to here.
Let's try to invoke it.
Hello GCP-- you've
got to have this.
Awesome
VILLE AIKAS: 2018, mate.
MARK CHMARNY: Ooh, 2019, good.
Almost as it we wanted
to show this way.
So let's come back
here and switch that
to '18, just to
show you how quickly
and easy is to deploy it.
Again, I didn't have
to do any new work,
just apply the exact same file.
Wait for Knative
to do its magic.
We're going to
talk about exactly
what is going on behind
the scene in a minute.
Wait for the three of three.
Switch over here.
OK, let's open it up.
Simple.
I wonder if my Chrome is
caching some things here.
There it is.
VILLE AIKAS: Yay,
back into reality.
All right.
Can we switch back to
the slides, please?
All right.
So that's great.
It's great to come
into a system where
you're going to have a really
nice, easy way to get started,
right?
Many of these-- so far, we
haven't shown you really
anything all that
special, right?
There's many tools that you
can already do this with today.
You can go ahead and
have template solutions.
You can download things that
wire things for you already.
So that part is not
really all that exciting.
But one of the
things that we also
wanted to make sure that we
work very hard on designing
the system is to make sure that
we define very clear or set
of principled object, so you can
reason about the object model
that we have built.
So every object
that you see in the system, you
should be able to go and look
at it and then saying like, I
know exactly what that does.
If I need to do x, I know
what I need to look at.
So in Kubernetes today,
I like to think of it
as the assembly language
level for the cloud native
programming.
So there's a lot of very
good building blocks there.
And if you put them all
together just the right way,
it's going to be awesome.
But what we are
trying to do here
is build you maybe something
like a libc, standard lib,
something like that,
higher level primitives
that not everybody
has to build those.
Like in the bad
old days, everybody
was building their
own libraries.
OK?
So we started off with a
very simple object, right?
It took two things.
It says here's my code, run it.
And here's some
conflict with it.
And you can come
in and very easily
go ahead and iterate on
that, push some new code,
everything works fantastically--
almost fantastically.
So underneath, what
we did is we took
that service object and we
created a configuration out
of that.
So configuration is another
great practice that is taking
your software-- the code--
and the configuration
and putting them
together so that it's
a self-contained unit.
This is a pretty
standard practice
from Twelve-Factor, and
putting together all your stuff
in one place, and making sure
that doesn't get out of sync.
Whenever you make modifications
to the configuration object,
or when you create
one, underneath Knative
will go in and create
a revision out of that.
So you interact with the
configuration object,
and underneath, Knative will go
in and make a revision object
for you.
And whenever you
make a modification
to a configuration,
Knative will stamp out
a new version of revision.
So at the end of the day,
for every modification
that you have made, you will
have a new version of it,
so you have a linear history
of all the changes that
are being applied to your code.
So that's pretty nice, right?
What do I do with that?
Well, you probably want to
go ahead and put some traffic
into that.
And that's where we have
in our out object, right?
So we are now going ahead
and being able to come in
and saying, OK, great, I
have some software over there
that I built, and I can easily
go and make modifications
to it.
With the route object,
you can come in
and be very specific
about how traffic
flows into those objects.
So again, let's just pause
there just for a second.
So the roles and
responsibilities
are very clear here.
So if you look at the
top of the box, service.
That is very dev-opish, right?
You're basically
pushing a code in.
Whenever you make a
change, it goes out
and starts serving traffic.
And as you grow, you can
start seeing we are going down
the stack a little
bit, where you can say,
hm, maybe I have a
clear operator role,
where the operator is
responsible for shuffling
my traffic.
And the developer can go ahead
and worry about pushing code.
So let's go and see
what that looks like.
So again, great on day one--
it was good to be in that
land of just push some code,
see it go live,
exciting, great times.
Then you start taking
some customers,
and you might want to change
your practice a little bit.
So let's see how
Knative grows with you.
So here's what we are
going to do now here.
We are just going to go through
a couple of slides together
here, just so we can
set the stage on what
it is that we are going to do.
And then Mark is going
to demo it after then.
But let's go ahead and
say, so this is roughly
what we had after we deployed
the very first version
of the software.
So we have a route that is
shuffling 100% of the traffic
to the configuration that
only has one revision.
That's all great.
So we are only specifying that
100% of the traffic goes there.
Now let's push some new code.
OK?
But we don't want to
shift any traffic to it
because we probably
want to validate
that that new version is.
So hopefully you
have some unit tests.
Don't look at me, Scott.
But then you might have some
integration tests as well.
And then you might want
to go ahead and test
your entire stack
against the new version
without affecting any of the
possible production traffic
that you have going on.
OK?
So what we do here is we go
into Knative, and we say,
hey, route, what
I would like to do
is I actually would like
to create two targets.
I'm going to go and create one
that is targeting my old one.
And I'm going to go and create
a new one for my second one,
the blue green one.
But I'm not going to
give it any traffic yet.
Oh, and also, please
give it a name
so I can talk about it, right?
Because that name is
not really friendly,
so give it a fancy name.
So push the new software,
no changes to your traffic.
Let's see this.
So then typically
you would maybe
start rolling out your
traffic a little bit.
You might say, OK, well
typically maybe 2% experiment,
or 50%, or whatever else it is.
But Mark likes to
live on the edge,
so he's just going
to go straight to 50.
I told him he's silly,
but, you know, whatever.
So now we are basically
going to go and say, great.
Let's go and do
50-50 traffic split,
just so we can see how things
work, because in a demo
it would be more
wonky to run at 2%.
And then in the end, once
we validate everything,
that's when we can go and shift
all of our production traffic
to the new version--
happy, making money.
And then we can turn
off the old version.
But we'll still leave
it around in case
we need to do a quick
little rollback.
We can do that, so let's
call that version 1.
So let's see what that looks
like on the demo machine,
please.
MARK CHMARNY: All right, so
what are we going to do here
is we're going to kind of go
through the same process--
oops, sorry.
Blue-green, there we go--
same process.
First of all, we're going to
deploy our basic application.
We've showed you how
to do this before,
so I'm not going to talk
too much about that, just
to create the initial
state, what would happen
when you deploy your stack.
So this is blue-green, and we're
going to talk about stage one.
So let's deploy that.
Wait for Knative to create
the instance of that,
all the necessary resources.
You see some activity
going on here.
And magic happens.
There we go.
All right, so we have
our instance stood up.
It runs.
The day one, the joy of
deploying software is there.
Everything is great.
But then you say, well,
I would like my thing
to be something better or to
fix them some [INAUDIBLE]..
So let's go over here and
take a look at the stage two.
Very much the same deployment,
another revision just
like we've done before,
another configuration,
but in addition to
this, we also are
going to create that
Initial Routes tab
that Ville was talking about.
So 100% to this old version,
0% to the new version.
Of course, deploying
application that
doesn't have a way to access
to it would not be fun,
so we give it a name
route so we can get to it.
So let's deploy the
stage two in here.
Again, we're going to wait
for this to magically happen.
All right, I can start
switching over here.
And now what I can do is I
can continue refreshing this.
You will see the
traffic continues
going to the original version.
But the beauty of this is that
now we have this v2 in here
that I can also peek at, even
though 100% of the traffic
is not going-- none of the
traffic is going over there.
All right, so now we've
done with revisions.
We've basically deployed two
versions of the application.
From now onwards,
all we're going to do
is we're just going to deal
with that route object in here.
By the way, is this big enough?
Everybody can see over there?
So in here, we're going to do
this very aggressive switching.
For the purposes
of demo, we're just
going to go 50-50
because I don't want
hit Command-R too many times.
So let's apply this.
Oops-- stage three--
actually, let's wait
for a second here.
It's all routes, so there
is nothing magical here.
So going back to the
original traffic,
50-50 is happening now.
It's not science.
So it's round robin
of some sorts.
And then now that we are
successful that that stage
of where we fixed everything
and we want to deploy,
we're shifting, or setting, the
traffic to the original version
to zero.
We're migrating everything
to the new version.
Oh, and by the way, just to kind
of have a historical reference
to get to the previous
version, we're
going to name a new route that
will allow us to go to v1.
Again, no magic in here.
Let's finish this.
Switch over here.
Let's just wait for
this for a second.
All right, there's still
a straggler in there.
Nope.
I'm pretty sure my crumb
is caching something.
There we go.
100% of the traffic,
and we still can--
so you have seen with
V1-- with V2 before.
We can still reach
to the old version
if we wanted to explicitly.
All right, can you
switch back to slides?
[APPLAUSE]
VILLE AIKAS: All
right, so a couple
of things that are
interesting about that demo
that I'd really
wanted to point now,
which is as we started
with the original one, that
was really easy to come
in and get started.
And it was more like, again,
with the devops model,
where we just push code.
Everything goes through.
By introducing configuration
and route objects,
now what you can do is
you can go ahead and start
defining not only roles
within your organization,
but also with these objects
by introducing things
like RBAC rules.
So you can say, OK devs, you
can push code all day you want.
But none of it is going
to make it into production
because I will be in control
of the route object, which
seems nice.
So OK, so that was great.
So we talked about how
to get the code out there
in the cloud.
Everything is hunky dory happy.
But, Knative, what have you
done for me lately, right?
So let's go ahead
and talk a little bit
about some of the other
aspects of serverless
that are typically
things that you
want to have out of the system.
So the first one
that we're going
to talk is the, when you leave
work, you're halfway to home,
and then you realize,
oh my goodness,
did I leave the stove on, right?
So this is equivalent
of, you know,
did I just spin up a
whole massive stack
that is going to be running
there the whole weekend,
burning cash, money flying out?
So, Knative, can you
take care of that for me?
So one part of the
serverless is you
don't think about serverless.
So why would you care about
it if you left the stove on?
Knative should be able
to say, you know what?
It's not in use.
Let me go and put it away.
That's great.
The other way that
it handles is,
there's this very unbursty--
sorry, unbursty-- bursty--
that's bursted traffic, right?
Traffic pattern it's
not always like this.
So your software makes it
into the Reddit or Hacker News
or whatever the greatest
new thing is that you
find the software, right?
So you're going to
get some new users.
And you're going to bursted
traffic and everything else.
You don't want to have to worry
about how many servers do I
have running, and did
I bring up enough pods,
and did I do this and
that and everything else?
Knative should just handle
that for you as well.
And also, it's easy to go
and take away resources
when they are not in use.
It's not so easy to
go and bring them
up when they
actually are needed.
So going from one
to zero is actually
pretty straightforward.
You just delete things.
But it's more tricky to
go and bring them back
when they are actually needed
to go and service requests
when the traffic
actually comes back up.
So let's go ahead and see how
Knative handles this for us,
kind of behind the scenes.
Can we switch to the
demo machine, please?
MARK CHMARNY: The demo, please.
Thank you.
All right so to do
this, we're going
to use the very
first application we
deployed during the first demo.
As you can see,
however, that demo
is not here because, thankfully,
I was afraid that some of you
were going to go to the
browser and start hitting it.
Nobody went there, and therefore
there was no traffic to it.
So let's see what
would happen if I
start accessing this again.
Knative, behind
the scene, start,
while holding the
traffic and kind
of waiting for the resource,
the necessary pod to be spun up,
brought it in.
And there is our demonstration.
[APPLAUSE]
So this was the cold
start experience--
the famous cold start
that everybody talks about
in still very complex situation.
But Knative does
the first attempt
at solving that problem.
Now I'm not going to
go here with a browser
and started hitting
it a million times.
We're going to go and
use a synthetic load--
VILLE AIKAS:
(WHISPERING) Cheater.
MARK CHMARNY: [LAUGHS]
Cheater, yeah--
synthetic load to spin up
about 20 different threads
with 10,000 requests
for each one of those.
And switch over here.
Now Knative's going
to go and start
provisioning the necessary
pods and everything.
Watching command
line and watching
Kubernetes provision pods is as
exciting as watching paint dry,
I guess.
So let's switch over to
an instance of our Grafana
here that comes with
Knative pre-configured.
It comes with a number
of different dashboards
that the Knative team,
K-native native team,
has provisioned
nicely for us here.
I'm going to use two ones.
First of all, we're going to
take a look at the traffic.
Let's maybe go a
little to future here.
You will see three lines.
I'm colorblind, so I'm going
to tell you what they told me
what the colors look like.
But we will see the
green line, which
is the actual number of pods.
We will see the desired number
of pods, what Knative thinks
you should have in order
to solve that traffic,
and the number of requested.
And you will see that, over us--
let's switch over
here very quickly.
I'll show you the number of pods
that Knative spun here for you.
There we go.
There's some activity
going on, I would say.
And refreshing-- we see that
this kind of what do you want,
what you get, and go on.
In addition to that, you can
also use a requester dashboard
in here.
Hopefully it choose
the right application.
And refresh this.
Why are we not seeing
any traffic in here?
Well, there is the first
demo crash I think.
All right, we should see the
number of requests coming in
for that request.
I'm using simple.
Oh, it might be something with
our mice, my time in here.
All right, hopefully the
other one was better.
There we go.
VILLE AIKAS: (WHISPERING)
Way to break it.
MARK CHMARNY:
Already broke a demo.
Now the other thing
that's going to go on,
if as soon as the demo
finishes, which it's done,
you will see the Knative
start decommissioning
the no-longer-necessary pods.
So we'll go in and start--
there we go.
I was hoping for that to happen,
just like Ryan yesterday.
I got just as lucky
as he did yesterday--
[INAUDIBLE] the pods as the
requests starts coming in.
Can we change back to slides?
Sorry, we warned
you there was going
to be a lot of switching there.
VILLE AIKAS: So that
was pretty nice.
And there was a couple
of things that I
don't know if somebody caught.
So you could see how the
blue-green deployments
were going away as well.
So those things are all
configurable for you
so you can decide what is the
sleep-off, how long things hang
around before they are
considered obsolete-- well,
not obsolete, but before we
can put them to bed for a bit.
So that's great.
So now we have sort
of kind of shown you
how you can go and get
the software on the cloud,
and manage it, and
things like that.
And we've sort of kind
of shown you how Knative
comes in and takes
away some of the things
that you really don't care
about in the serverless land.
Also, what Knative does
for you is handling going
from source to code, right?
So if you caught all the
examples we showed you so far,
we're just taking a pointer
to a container, right?
So again, as a
developer, I typically
don't care about that.
I just want to
write the software.
And I want to say, run the
software, not the container.
There's a difference there.
Just run my code.
So we also have a building
repo that allows you to come in
and say, OK my
code is over there
in the Git, or Cloud Storage,
or something like that.
And you can come in and
say, please, take that code.
Just run it.
I don't care about the bill.
Do it.
So why do you, as
a developer, care?
Well, again, once you go
and get up your laptop,
all the tools are installed
and everything else,
and the project
grows a little bit,
then you get your friend
working on it too,
and they have a
different laptop.
And then you start
getting all those fun
cross-compiling problems,
and the cross image,
and nothing works anymore.
So now you can go and have an
easy way to go ahead and say,
you know what?
Let's do the build
one way just once.
That seems better, right?
There's also no need for
Docker locally, right?
So that's nice.
Less things I need
to do on my machine,
less things I need to
upgrade, less things
I need to keep running.
Great, perfect, right?
Also, there's performance
improvements out of this one.
Because when I'm
running in the cloud,
I can take advantage
of the cloud caching.
So typically the machines in the
cloud have much bigger pipes.
So they can suck bytes
in and out faster, right?
I can also take advantage
of caching behavior
of things like image layers.
So if you're building
something, chances
are somebody else is building at
least lower, middle-level parts
of it, and your code
goes on the top there.
And then the nice thing
is that because it all
happens in the cloud, now you
can go start creating things
like audit logs.
You can go and add
additional things
into this tool chain that allows
you to go ahead and say, hm,
who did what, when, and why?
And again, this is something
that is loosely coupled.
So one of the things
we don't want to do
is we don't want to come in and
say, in order to use Knative,
you must do things this
way every single time.
So in the first
examples we showed you,
bring your own toolchain, right?
So many of you might already
have a CI/CD pipeline running.
Great.
Everybody's happy.
But this allows you to also
go and say, you know what?
I don't really
necessarily need that.
Let's just go ahead
and use this one.
Or if you're coming
in from the otherland,
where you are
running into GitHub
and building on
the local machine,
it allows you to
move into the land
where you're coming in and
saying like, you know what?
Just handle it for me.
And then maybe out of that you
graduate again to some CI/CD
pipeline and whatever else.
And that's all fine and dandy.
But again, these are
the kinds of things
that Knative does for
you automagically,
giving you that serverless
thing, serverless kind of--
I don't want to call it promise,
but let's call it promise.
It's just like going from source
to running code, that's great.
There it is.
And also, the, hey, I don't
worry about the infrastructure,
right?
So so far we haven't done
anything here dealing
with machines or
lower-level details,
except when we actually go look
and make sure that something
is actually happening.
It would be a boring demo
if we didn't do that.
So we just kind of
show those to you.
But you don't have
to worry about that.
So let's look at the next slide.
Oops, sorry.
OK.
MARK CHMARNY: Demo.
VILLE AIKAS: Yes.
So let's switch to the demo
and see what this looks like.
MARK CHMARNY: OK, thank you.
So what we're going
to do here, we're
going to take the
traditional GitHub operation.
So we're going to take GitHub
repository or Git Repository
hosted on GitHub.
We're going to, in
this case, we're
going to follow a very
simple application that
probably is as simple as
one could create a web
server with in Go.
But I'm sure there's
some room to improve it.
And it has a Docker
file in here to specify
how I would like to build this.
Obviously, this would apply
for different languages
in different kind
of formats there.
So what we're going to do
here is let's fire this job
so we can talk about it.
Source-- all right,
so while this is--
while Knative is spinning
up the resources,
let's take a look at
the manifest that was
used in this particular case.
Again, we're building
from GitHub repo.
Knative supports both public
repositories as well as secrets
for private repos,
so you don't have
to be dependent on exposing
the entire thing to the world.
And we're going to have a
couple of components in here.
First of all is the
configuration component
of the build process, which
will include the source bit,
which will indicate the
source of the source,
as in the repository from
which we want to pull,
as well as the branch
we want to pull from.
So it supports
multiple branches.
In addition to this,
we're going to specify
a particular template.
Knative supports a number
of different templates.
We're going to use, in
this case, a cononical,
which is an open
source project that's
also already public,
to create an image that
will be pushed when done
to a image repository.
Knative also provide
certain kind of shortcuts.
So we're going to define a
variable in here, called image,
that will hold this URL.
So in the rest of
the configuration,
we can just use that variable.
The beauty of this is
that when we come in here,
when we start talking
about the actual target
of the deployment, we're going
to specify we want a target--
deploy this as an application.
We want to use the
URL of the image
once was published to
the image repository.
And we're also are going
to define the environment
variables that we've
talked about before,
the same way you would
have done for any other
of the application.
So let's take a look
at where we are.
Looks like image is still
being built. What Knative does
is has a multi-phase
process involved in here.
So it, first of all, pulls
all the necessary resources.
It does certain months
of configuration in it.
Then once the image
is built, publishes
the image then turns around
and uses the image just like it
did if you were building,
deploying an application
from a published image.
In this case, we're seeing a--
two of three, almost there.
There we go.
So let's take a look at this--
what is it?
--source image.
And there we go.
[APPLAUSE]
VILLE AIKAS: All right.
Can we switch back to
the slides, please?
OK.
So the nice thing about--
one additional thing I
wanted to point out here
is that another reason why
you might want to about this
is this is totally
pluggable, so that you
can go ahead and have different
kinds of pipelines here.
So, for example, some people
have built things like .Net
pipelines.
So you can go and build
things like that there.
There's build-back
support and so forth.
So that's also very
nice and customizable.
So it's not only just Docker
thingies that we built.
All right, so, great.
So so far again, we've
talked a little bit
about some aspects
of serverless.
But sometimes it seems like--
MARK CHMARNY: What has come
to be the norm [INAUDIBLE]..
There you go.
VILLE AIKAS: There we go.
Am I there?
Yeah, OK, great.
I am here, yes.
OK, so it seems that
over the last few years,
it seems like what has come
to be the norm for serverless
is serverless equals,
equals, equals functions.
That's all it is, right?
Well, with Knative,
there's bigger things
that we are worrying
about, which
is serverless is much,
much bigger than functions.
So we've been doing
serverless for a long time
with App Engine, so we are kind
of like trying to bring the two
things together.
However, the one nice
thing about the serverless,
the programming
model that typically
resonates with most developers
is the eventing-driven one.
So I have written some
software, and when
I hit it with the browser,
that is still event-drive.
I'm coming in and saying,
could you do something for me?
But what we have
done with the Knative
is really given a
first-class principal
objects for describing where
those events are coming from.
So on the bottom right there,
we have the event consumers.
So those are the things
that we have been
deploying all day long so far.
So there's nothing different
about those things.
We are just pushing
code, rolling it forward,
doing our testing,
and everything else.
So those are the
event consumers OK?
On the top right, we
have the event sources.
So something is producing
events for me, right?
So this might be, for
example, a GitHub.
So GitHub has a very
rich eventing source.
Kubernetes cluster itself
is very, very rich.
Anything that happens in the
cluster, chances are it's
pushing out events.
For each one of
the event sources,
there's typically more
than one event type,
so the kind of
event it supports.
So, for example, the GitHub,
you have a pull request.
So if somebody
comes in and says,
hey, here's a pull request,
or if I make a commit,
those two events are very
different in their context.
And so there is this
one-to-many relationship
in Knative for event
sources and event types.
And so what is
left then is, OK, I
have those event
types and sources,
and I have my code here.
How do I wire them together?
And for that there is
an object called AFLOW.
So with the flow,
you go ahead and say,
Mr. Knative, go over there.
Take those events from there
and wire them over to here.
So let's go and see what
this looks like in practice
if we were to go ahead and--
to see how seamless it
is to go ahead and go
from the application
during programming or just
the pure container model, to
the function and programming,
using the same tool sets.
Can we switch the
demo machine, please?
MARK CHMARNY: Almost done,
couple more switches.
Right, so to illustrate
this, what we're going to do
is we're actually going to
wire the Knative into an event
stream that's coming
from IoT devices.
Google has a product called IoT
Core that provides an easy way,
like a gateway, for registering
devices and securely
managing them with keys.
So what we've done here is we've
created one of those gateways.
No code required,
it's just simply
a GUI operation that defined
two different types of protocols
we're going to be receiving
on, MPTT and HTTP,
define our mocked-up
IoT device, because I
couldn't get one of those
from our team over there.
And it's called Net 18--
sorry, Next 18.
And we're also going to--
by default, what
IoT Core does, it
create a like sync
for all those events.
So in this case, we're going
to have two topics on Pub/Sub.
Pub/Sub is the message
broker in Google Cloud.
That one is for IoT data,
so that data itself.
The other one is metadata
about the devices that connect.
So you can event on
things like my device has
connected or disconnected,
or a certain threshold.
So this is our source of events.
What are we going to do here?
We're going to go in and
switch quickly and take a look
at the actual code itself.
Now event-flow, there we go.
Let's take a look
at first the code
that we used to publish it.
All we've done here--
yeah, we have some Go, Go
things like defining the types.
But bottom line is, we've
done one function that
handles the events that are
going to be passed to me.
The cool thing about it is
that, in this entire code,
there's no references to Pub/Sub
or any proprietary Google code.
You wrote idiomatic Go
language that receives events.
This works for Node.
This works for any other
language you can support it
within the runtime on Knative.
And when you do this--
again, we're not going
do any fancy thing.
So we're basically just going
to print this entire thing
to command line and see
what's going to happen.
So let's take a look at
the flow, the configuration
portion of the entire thing.
Similarly to all the other way
with configuring applications,
we're going to have a
principal object that's
defined by Knative,
the flow object, that
defines the name and all
the other parameters.
And it has two components.
One is the trigger,
as in what do
we want to connect to
from the source of events.
It includes the name of the
project, as well as the topic,
as well as the
connection that is
the target for where the
events should be processed for.
Nothing new in here,
we're deploying
a simple function,
which is going
to be representing the route.
So let's go and apply this.
Up-- flow-- there we go.
We should see some additional
resources being created,
I think.
Oh, that's great.
That's just great.
VILLE AIKAS: (WHISPERING)
You broke it again.
MARK CHMARNY: There we go.
Hoo!
All right, what
Knative is doing now
is going through the operation
of provisioning [INAUDIBLE]..
Now again, let's
fire the switch over
here and generate some data.
So we're going to
go and generate--
gen-- generate MPTT data.
This is going to
be super simple.
It's a simple object
that represents
a source of the event, the
unique identifier for each one
of those events,
and some time stamp,
and a random number
between 1 and 10.
This is as sophisticated as
it's is going to get today,
I'm afraid.
And then let's switch over here.
And what we will see, that
using that configuration,
we were able to--
let's do this.
Let's take that IoT and
decrease the noise level in
here a little.
A pod-- container user--
container-- no.
Well, it's helpful when
you spell it correctly.
Container-- what we see
is the output of those.
I haven't written
any specific code
other than a function
that handles events.
All the plumbing of that into
that code, into the route,
was handle for me.
You're still benefiting from all
the other principal properties
of Knative, which is
the outer scaling, which
is the up and down scaling
and provisioning and all that.
[APPLAUSE]
VILLE AIKAS: Can we switch
back to slides, please?
Great.
So-- go to the next
slide for a second.
Grade.
OK, so just to make it more
concrete, what we just saw
was we basically had the
Go function on the bottom
that Mark wrote.
But again, we have
deployed that previously
because one of the concepts
of wanting to demonstrate
is the notion of late binding.
So you want to go and
define your function.
You want to run the function.
You want to go ahead
and roll that forward,
independent of how it is
wired to something else.
So the function is
happily running.
Notice it was
sleeping there, right?
It was getting no traffic.
And then it came up when
we started getting that.
And the Pub/Sub event
source and the topic
were our event
source's name and types
in this particular instance.
Those are user defined also.
So you can come in if you have
some existing systems that you
want to go and wire in.
There's a way to come in
there and extend the system
by providing glue logic to say,
OK, this is how you go ahead
and configure things.
And the topics of subscription
that Mark showed for the flow
was precisely that.
It says, there's
the GCP Pub/Sub.
I want to go and get
events from this topic.
And I want them wired
into this Go function.
So that was pretty simple.
Again, it was very,
very nice way.
What we didn't show you there
is that the nice thing is
there's a clear lifecycle here.
So once you come in and you
delete that flow object,
it's going to go
away and clean up.
So, for example, Pub/Sub
resources are deleted.
And again, it decouples
the even production
from the consumer, which
is a very nice property.
Now underneath again,
there's a lot of complexity
that we don't get a
chance to show here.
But there is
additional resources
that typically are facing
the operator persona here,
so things like
channels and buses
so that the traffic is shuffling
through there and so forth.
But again, because
we are focusing
on what the developer
sees, this as the developer
experience right here.
We are really piggybacking off
of CNC of cloud event support.
So a lot of our
friends at Google
and colleagues over
at other companies
have been working on
standardizing the cloud events,
trying to make sure that, in
the near future, that there's
standardization on what
flows on the wire there
and how do you consume
events and things like that.
So we are using that.
And if you looked at the
code, we have Go types,
and that's because,
well, that code
was written a little while ago.
By now there is a cloud
of end support there too.
So, yay.
But anyways, so that's
our eventing story.
So we started this
whole talk about saying,
yay, you should come take a look
at Knative because it helps you
as the developer.
So how did we do, Mark?
MARK CHMARNY: All
right, so let's
go back to this original list.
Again, developers just
want to write the code,
don't want to do anything else.
We showed you certain
demos that kind of
illustrated the capabilities
that Knative enables
the developers to
not have to worry
about building Docker images.
So frankly, you can be
a developer on Knative
and not have any Docker
components installed locally,
any doc, any image
builds tools whatsoever.
None of the pushing to registry
either, deploy services,
we don't have to worry about
if we simply push the code,
exposing this to the routes.
The routes were creating
for us automatically.
The logging and
monitoring was enabled.
Although, it looks like one of
those monitoring capabilities
was broken today.
And we showed you also scaling,
so scaling from 0 to 1,
1 to 0, and 1 to n in whatever
order you want to go there.
So lots of room
to improve still,
but many of the boring, the
plumbing related activities
the developer has to do
every day hundreds of times
if they're really
developing, is handle for you
by Knative automatic--
K-native automatically.
Knative is also extendable.
Now any software that
anybody has ever written,
implements opinions,
opinions of the developer.
Knative is no different.
It implements
opinions that we have,
based on the years of learning
from developing software
at Google, at the scale
that Google operates,
including implements opinions
of the partners and contributors
to the project.
But from the very beginning,
it was very important for us
that these opinions are not
held very, very tightly,
that we can change those
as the use cases come up.
Serverless is still very
beginning stages, frankly,
at very, very beginning stages.
And things will evolve.
So we want to make sure that
those opinions can be replaced
when to use case
you're working on
is not being served by the
capabilities at Knative.
So a lot of that is built,
is baked right into the API.
That means event
sources and types,
I think if you go to our
GitHub repository today,
you will see
examples for Pub/Sub.
You will see GitHub.
You will see a
couple of other ones.
But it is not a large
portfolio of events.
We are going to
get better there.
It includes support for a
number of different build packs.
The Pivotal team
has, for example,
provided a build pack for C#
that we have not developed.
So you can extend
those and configure
this post-installation
on Knative.
It includes a lot of
network configuration.
So, for example, for
the demonstration
today, we are using GCP gateway.
We're using SSL
configuration that
was enabled us to buy Knative
IP configuration for static IP,
as number of different variables
they're logging and tagging.
Now Knative, K-native,
not obfuscate Kubernetes.
Underneath it's
still Kubernetes.
And you have still access to it.
In fact, I was using
the very same tool
you're using to manage
Kubernetes itself.
So if you feel like,
you could come in
and change some of
the implementations
that we've done, including
the auto-scaling strategy.
I showed you auto-scaling
based on number of requests.
You could base this on
latency to connection
to the database or
something like that.
I don't recommending doing
that on the first day playing
with Knative, but you could.
Functions invokers--
the community at large
is working on the best way
of implementing this for Go,
or Python, or Node.js,
different message boxes
that you can implement.
There is a lot of different
customization options.
All right, we have
three minutes to go.
And we do want to leave
some time for questions.
So there's a couple
of links in here.
First of all, everything
we've shown you today
is reproducible.
If you go to our documents
repository in Knative.org.
You can get there,
start from there,
and it will navigate
to everywhere else.
You could also,
if you don't want
to play the role of a operator,
which for the purposes of demo
I was playing, we have a
sign-on for early access
to serverless
add-on on GKE, which
will do all of that for
you with a single command.
Give me Knative-- boom, done.
Or give me a
serverless stack, which
is kind of using the components
that were released later
as open source for Knative.
We also have a pretty
vibrant community already.
So if you looked at it
and go, you know what?
This sounds interesting.
I would love to contribute.
Or these guys don't
know what they're doing.
Let me tell you.
Let me show you how
it's really done.
All right, come in here,
the community inside
of our repository is
a good place to start.
It talks about the
code of conduct,
talks about the kind of
how it gets you started.
It even highlights best
to start with issues
that are already out there.
And trust me, there's
a bunch of devs there.
And as any hip
project nowadays, we
have a Slack
channel that's open.
Not sure that exact
URL works right now.
But if you go to
the GitHub repo,
if you follow the instructions
there, it will go.
The self-registration in
Slack it is not smooth.
Ville and I would love
to hear your feedback.
We would love to hear your
comments after the session
or right now.
VILLE AIKAS: Yeah,
please, please, please,
do us one favor and go to your
handy-dandy mobile devices,
or however you fill out the
form that says how we did.
It's very important to us.
Because if we get
no information,
then we can't improve.
So please take the time.
It should be very, very quick.
MARK CHMARNY: Thank you.
VILLE AIKAS: Thank you so much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]